encargado para América Latina del
departamento de estado dijo que Estados
Unidos está dispuesto a participar en la
conferencia internacional para resolver
la crisis política en Venezuela que
convocará el presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro en Bogotá en los próximos
días dijo en Washington que hay
preocupación por la situación del pueblo
venezolano y que cualquier país que esté
aportando sus buenos votos y buenos
oficios para mejorar la situación es
algo importante la disponibilidad para
asistir a este encuentro se da Después
de que el presidente colombiano Gustavo
Petro anunciara su intención de convocar
ese foro mientras una amplia delegación
del gobierno colombiano está en este
momento en Washington en un diálogo de
alto nivel entre Estados Unidos y
Colombia en el que abordaron entre otros
asuntos la cooperación regional
Precisamente en el marco de este diálogo
de alto nivel el canciller colombiano
Álvaro Leyva Durán el ministro de
Justicia Néstor Osuna y el embajador de
Colombia en Washington Luis Gilberto
Murillo se reunieron con varios
senadores en el Capitolio entre ellos
James Rich de Idaho quien tras la
reunión publicó un comunicado diciendo
que se mantiene preocupado de que
Colombia haya restablecido relaciones
diplomáticas económicas y de seguridad
con el régimen de maduro y agregó que
maduro no Debería ser tratado como un
actor internacional de buena fe opinión
que comparten varios congresistas
republicanos en Washington